the omicron variant as you know still
surging nationwide and putting a strain
on nearly every aspect of american life
in this country in just 24 hours on
monday the u.s saw more than 1.4 million
new covet cases that number has never
been higher a hearing with top health
officials on capitol hill yesterday
including included rather some very
intense criticism over the scarcity of
covet tests and the mixed messaging on
how to react if you get a positive
result
the acting fda chief that's janet
woodcock told the panel at some point
most people most people in this country
will get covet all this is worsening the
crisis at many american schools that are
just trying to keep your children safe
while also keeping them busy learning
mark strassman is following that part of
the story in mobile alabama
school is back in session across almost
all of the country schools should be the
first places to open and the last places
to close and the nation's top health
officials say the safety of students and
staff is their top priority first and
foremost one of the most important
things that's changed is we should be
getting our children and our teenagers
vaccinated across covenant america 5400
schools reported omicron's surge
disrupted in-class learning last week
this week that number already tops 3
000.
in los angeles more than 400 thousand
students returned to class tuesday amid
a surge in coveted cases across the city
school district
the latest data showing nearly 60
thousand active cases among students and
staff about 15 percent of the tests
submitted there's a lot of widespread
infection in the school students in
brooklyn took matters into their own
hands staging a walkout tuesday in
protest over in-person teaching mandates
but some programs are finding their way
at this 9 000 acre preserve in lafarge
wisconsin a new kindergarten program
embraces the benefits of outdoor
learning
[Music]
and discovered a pandemic safe space at
the peak of
an outbreak that we had we had 28 active
cases among students and staff and how
about in this program how many kids zero
none
coincidence probably not
seventeen schools in portland maine also
built outdoor learning spaces plenty of
winter gear and wi-fi
6 700 students k-12 spend part of their
day outdoors but what we've found is
just that the
students
are loving those teachers are using the
school grounds in ways that they did not
before
here in alabama school staffing has been
an issue since the start of the pandemic
with the omicron surge the number of
cases among students and staff has
nearly quadrupled this week to 3 000
pushing some school systems into remote
learning and i should point out too that
alabama has one of the lowest child
vaccination rates in the country
tony
winter plus remote learning very hard on
parents mark thank you very much